[Musica]
Enrica mi ha dato un assist meraviglioso
Perché quando ringrazio i ragazzi e le
ragazze di tedex mi hanno invitato qui a
a Vasto mi hanno detto il tema è va bene
tutto ho pensato Ma che minchia di
tema Cioè mi sono bloccato e ho detto io
adesso che cosa dico allora in realtà
c'è un tema che io sto sviscerando molto
negli ultimi anni giusto per dare una
botta di entusiasmo in questa chiusura
di tedex Vasto ovvero il tema del
fallimento ho scritto un
Oh tipo Pensavo nel tema della
lasagna e quindi ho pensato che va bene
tutto va bene anche
fallire Ok non dobbiamo forse
vergognarcene di dire
ehm ma non nel senso americano del
termine Enric lo diceva molto meglio di
me cioè no dai sei caduto ti rialzi sei
caduta ti rialzi sei meglio di prima No
no no no neanche nel senso del metodo
scientifico cioè provo sbaglio imparo
riprovo sbaglio imparo come ci ha
spiegato anche Ale no No intendo proprio
il fallimento in cui cadi stai fermo
piangi e stai E ci pensi stai lì ok e
per farlo vorrei iniziare con questo
[Musica]
video
è più famoso di me non ci sono dubbi su
questo chiaro ha vinto i Grammy Questi
erano i Grammy di quest'anno ha vinto i
gremmi dici Cavoli figata questo questa
esibizione live perché era tutto in ha
dentro un fallimento clamoroso Ma
nessuno se n'è accorto nessuna se n'è
accorto
ehm il disco che su cui giravano i
ballerini hanno fatto una coreografia in
cui hanno provato 12 ballerini per 10
giorni e il disco girava in senso
antiorario Inizia la diretta e il disco
in che parte gira Secondo voi in senso
orario dici minchia No l'ho provata in
senso antiorario adesso come faccio e
infatti i ballerini Come avete visto si
alzano e dicono Aspetta ho tutti i punti
che cardinali completamente ribaltati
Come faccio e c'era uno in mezzo così
che stava aspettando di capire anche
perché la regia non si poteva chiamare
in diretta Scusa puoi far girare il
disco dall'altra parte
no poteva andare un disastro ma il
pubblico non lo sapeva il pubblico non
sa cosa doveva succedere ok Quindi non è
stato un fallimento ha vinto il Grammy
alla faccia Questo esempio qua mi ha
fatto venirea in mente il mio lavoro io
per 12 anni come hanno detto i
conduttori ho fatto l'autore di un
programma non so se alcuni di voi lo
conoscono Si chiama La Zanzara è
condotto da Giuseppe Cruciani e fare
l'autore per un programma di quel genere
lì vuol dire non accettare il fallimento
perché se carichiamo un ospite che non è
buono non risponde un ascoltatore o un
file è corrotto m la cosa non va proprio
benissimo e quindi ho dovuto fare i
conti con il fallimento molte molte
volte con questo concetto non lo accetto
ancora adesso non lo accetto ancora oggi
Beh insomma si è chiaro io non sono hry
Styles quello è Semmai Giuseppe Cruciani
Io in caso ero il ballerino al centro
del disco che si alzava piano piano e
che cercava durante la diretta di dire
aspetta prendi tutti i pezzi e tienli
incollati tra loro Fai in modo che
arriviamo in qualche modo a a portare a
termine questo programma Questa
trasmissione 2 ore e mezza ogni giorno
in diretta dal lunedì al venerdì sabato
alla domenica mi ricoverano in ospedale
cioè
ehm Ovviamente io faccio un lavoro in
cui ho il privilegio di poter fallire
sia chiaro cioè immaginatevi essere
sotto un chirurgo e che ti dice B ho
visto un tedex a Vasto dice che posso
fallire Ecco non in questo momento
dottore Possibilmente non in questo
momento Ehm ma non voglio limitare
neanche il concetto di fallimento
soltanto al mondo lavorativo perché
sennò è riduttivo rientriamo sempre
nella solita logica e io appunto ho
lasciato la zanzara Dopo 12 anni i miei
amici mi hanno detto ma sei scemo il
programma più famoso della radiofonia
italiana è un fallimento totale e io
l'ho vissuto come tale anche lasciare
questo programma da un anno mi occupo di
podcast e poi ho lasciato la mia
compagna dopo 16 anni di relazione
tragedia e e per me il fallimento più
alto è stato quello di andare dallo
psicologo cioè io pensavo che nessuna
persona oltre a me stesso potesse
comprendermi e capire chi sono e quindi
andare dallo psicologo era tipo
attestato di fallimento massimo in
realtà mi sbagliavo perché Come mi ha
insegnato la mia psicologa che penso sia
ancora viva dopo aver trattato me ehm il
fallimento vuol dire Accettare la
propria vulnerabilità vulnerabilità non
ha un'accezione è abbastanza neutra
anche se viene da vulnus da mancanza
però è è qualcosa che possiamo accettare
tutti quanti
ehm questa vulnerabilità nella nostra
società non viene molto accettata c'è un
libro molto bello di Maura gangitano e
Andrea colamedici un collettivo si
chiama tlon Che ci racconta come la
nostra società sia impermea della dalla
performance lo diceva Bene Enrica No
dobbiamo sempre dare il meglio di noi
stessi ma per fortuna si stanno creando
delle fratture in questa narrazione
molto interessante con le nuove
generazioni che sui social ci fanno
vedere il brutto ci fanno vedere quello
che non funziona Avete presente gli
influencer che vanno in giro e vedono
cioè nei viaggi ci fanno vedere delle
storie bellissime tutto perfetto c'è lo
scivol Bali che entra nell'acqua c'è la
colazione perfetta Ecco fortunatamente
non siamo più in quel periodo storico lì
possiamo far vedere che se ti butti
nell'acqua Bali ci sono gli squali
esattamente lì dove ti sei buttato tu Ok
ehm e quindi il concetto di
vulnerabilità per me è è è molto è Non
so come dire lo uso anche perché
potrebbe fallire questo
tedex lo dico è vero potrebbe fallire No
ma potrebbe fallire anche
tranquillamente il mio speech È molto
facile che fallisca ehm la cosa
interessante è che noi veniamo fuori dal
fallimento eh C'è un libro di arari è
uno storico si chiama Sapiens d'animali
a dei Noi siamo questa parte qua questa
parte qua e ci dice che fino a una
decina di migliaia di anni fa sulla
faccia della terra c'erano sei specie
umane contemporaneamente che camminavano
quindi non c'erano solo i Sapiens
c'erano anche i Neandertal è un evidente
esempio il mio o qualche gene che gira
ancora da qualche parte c'erano i
denisova c'erano gli Erectus a un certo
punto il Sapiens ha vinto gli altri le
altre specie sono fall lite quindi noi
veniamo fuori da fallimenti successi ma
anche fallimenti e tra l'altro a costo
di gravi sacrifici perché noi abbiamo
una testa enorme rispetto alla colonna
che ci regge quanti di noi hanno mal di
schiena mal di collo Questo è l'esempio
di come l'evoluzione si è andata m m
Insomma un po' così per
adesso balzando da 102.000 anni fa ad
oggi noi stiamo cercando di fare di
tutto per far fallire il nostro sistema
il nostro ambiente
il cambiamento climatico lo vediamo a
settembre a Vasto ci sono 45° Ma cosa
avete fatto cioè io non vedo l'ora di
andare al mare adesso è fine settembre
inizio ottobre e noi cerchiamo di far
fallire il nostro contesto non
rendendoci conto che se fallisce quello
falliamo noi lo dice molto meglio di me
Stefano Mancuso che è un un botanico e
che racconta questa cosa per quanto mi
riguarda Io credo che le piante siano
più intelligente degli uomini
intelligenti nell'accezione
più basica del termine cioè nella
capacità di risolvere problemi la
dimostrazione di questo sta nel fatto
che noi ci troviamo in un momento della
nostra storia in cui rischiamo
addirittura che la nostra specie ne
abbia delle gravi conseguenze ci stiamo
in un certo senso autodistruggendo
stiamo
l'uomo come migliore di tutte le specie
io dico soltanto aspettiamo cos'è
l'obiettivo che tutte le specie hanno in
comune Beh questa è la sopravvivenza
della specie e la nostra specie è
estremamente giovane Noi abbiamo 300.000
anni Homo Sapiens la vita media di una
specie su questo pianeta è 5 milioni di
anni se noi fossimo come le altre specie
avremmo ancora 4. 700.000 anni davanti
che ad oggi sembra un orizzonte
francamente difficile da raggiungere Ma
se faremo tanto di estinguerci nei
prossimi 10.000 100.000 un milione di
anni avremmo dimostrato di essere
Indiscutibilmente una delle specie più
stupide mai apparse su questo pianeta
quindi Diamoci tempo il concetto è un
po' quello Ok Diamoci del tempo lo
scopriremo se siamo destinati a fallire
Sicuramente siamo sulla via giusta
Secondo me però a questo punto mi chiedo
è insito nel nostro DNA tutti quanti noi
abbiamo fallito perché non l'accettiamo
e ci viene un po' in aiuto un genetista
si chiama Richard Hawkins ha scritto un
bellissimo libro che si chiama il gene
egoista non so se l'avete letto in cui
ci racconta che i nostri geni ci portano
sempre a valutare il worst case lo
scenario peggiore in assoluto e poi con
la classica tecnica Fight or flight
Quindi o combatti oppure te ne vai via
ehm e e questo questo Gene qua è
talmente insito dentro di noi e fa un
esempio molto bello Tra l'altro
attualizzarsi non basta un elemento
positivo Mi verrebbe da dire mutuando
non basta una pesca per fare uno spot
pubblicitario bello
quello non l'hai fatto tu
vero E allora perché non riusciamo Siamo
siamo settati geneticamente per
accettare il fallimento perché noi non
siamo solo geni siamo anche Meme siamo
anche memetica siamo anche tradizione
culturale ci passiamo di generazione in
generazione uno stereotipo per cui il
genitore uomo maschio tornava a casa
dopo 10 ore di lavoro i figli li vedeva
per 2 ore il lavoro era la parte più
preponderante è la parte più
preponderante del nostro del nostro
essere e ci viene sempre raccontato che
se facciamo bene Adesso se se ci
impegniamo Eh hai voglia dopo i successi
viviamo da 2000 anni in una morale che
ci dice che se ci comportiamo bene
adesso dopo vergini cose di tutto
troveremo il ben di Dio nel vero senso
della parola
e Ma questa storia qua Boh non lo so
scricciola scricchiola un pochettino ehm
parlando di evoluzione eh Sapiens a n
arent diceva che siamo Homo faber quindi
siamo persone che lavorano e durante 24
ore non so chiedetevi Quante ore
lavorate voi in una giornata dei 24 io 8
9 10 le partite IVA Non ne parliamo non
staccano mai con lo Smart Working siamo
sempre reperibili giusto Ecco allora ho
pensato cos'è la cosa che fa più paura
la performance Qual è l'insuccesso il
fallimento più grande che viene
impersonificato da noi
Beh quando ozio
l'ozio una parola che fa timore sei
bloccato cioè il capitalismo vede l'ozio
e dice vabbè prendo un'altra strada Ciao
l'ozio per i latini andando alla radice
del termine era alla base del negozio
NEC ozium negare l'ozio per lavorare ma
per lavorare Dobbiamo pensare stare
oziare Allora adesso occhi aperti occhi
chiusi fate quello che volete vi chiedo
per 20 secondi pensavo all'inizio 30 ma
30 secondo me adesso scappate per andare
a mangiare per 20 secondi vi chiedo di
oziare nel vostro peggior fallimento
cioè proprio quello che dite No vabbè
Questo non lo posso raccontare neanche
al mio compagno e all mia compagna il
peggiore Non lo dovete dire quindi vi do
20 secondi e ragionateci state ozzate
nel
fallimento
il radio e il silenzio è tremendo vuol
dire che si è rotto qualcosa ve lo dico
quindi affrontare Per me questa paura
del silenzio È gigantesca per me è un
fallimento stare in silenzio per il mio
lavoro però questo silenzio ci insegna
anche che E l'avete sentito anche se non
visto sentito che ognuno di voi ha
pensato al proprio fallimento Ognuna di
voi ha pensato al proprio fallimento e
la cosa è che non siamo soli tutti
abbiamo fallito anche
lui lui è morto a 37 anni nel 1890
misero in miseria totale ha fatto più di
1000 disegni 900 dipinti un genio
assoluto lo amo alla follia è morto
misero ha fallito tecnicamente secondo
la nostra società ha fallito saltando
dall'800 e arrivando fino ai giorni
nostri SAV llan un regista francese che
ha detto io mi sono stufato di fare film
che non vede nessuno Mi ritiro basta
stop Tra l'altro film belli molto belli
però ha detto io in un'intervista a van
Fer ha detto io mi sono stufato di
fallire stop e l'ha messo Secondo me è
uno squarcio bellissimo oppure loro Cioè
non tecnicamente loro nel senso che loro
sono molto famosi e diciamo che hanno
spaccato i culi Come si diceva prima No
loro intendo Gli svedesi perché gli
svedesi Dio li abbia in gloria oltre
all'IKEA e Spotify hanno inventato una
cosa meravigliosa che è il museo del
fallimento
Ok R caschiamo nel capitalismo Perché
giustamente bisogna sempre guadagnarci
in qualche modo dai fallimenti però la
cosa che mi interessa è che Samuel West
che è l'ideatore del museo del
fallimento uno psicologo ha detto le
storie di successo sono tutte no
fottutamente lo dico io però tutte
fottutamente uguali tutte simili
noiosissime le storie di fallimento
invece hanno all'interno sempre qualcosa
di diverso di interessante di speciale
quindi facendo lo step job della
situazione dico siate speciali e
fallite Se non siete chirurghi
ovviamente Ok tra i prodotti più
interessanti di questo museo del
fallimento c'è questo che spero che
Vista l'ora non siate portati comunque a
mangiare perché la Colgate vabbè Fa dei
prodotti meravigliosi Spero non sia
sponsor del tedex di Vasto Ma insomma
però Ecco questo è un nel museo del
fallimento troviamo i prodotti che sono
falliti sul mercato proprio di quei
buchi atomici questo penso che boh
qualcuno di voi l'ha mai assaggiata sta
roba No non sarebbe qua a raccontarcelo
evidentemente
Allora per lasciarci con un minimo di
slancio perché sennò veramente ci
buttiamo giù dalla finestra Mi vengono
in soccorso i future studies che sono
questa questa disciplina che studia i
futuri mi piace molto usare il termine
futuri al plurale perché così non ci
blocca soltanto su un'immagine che
abbiamo di noi unica univoca quindi
future studies ci dicono di ragionare in
diversi futuri e tra questi futuri Io
sto sforzando su me stesso di metterci
dentro il fallimento realmente
sinceramente che se capita almeno lo so
e mi posso accucciare piangere e stare
sereno ehm il fallimento poi di fatto
che cos'è è la distanza tra ciò che noi
ci aspettiamo avvenga e ciò che succede
veramente Ehm tutti quanti qua hanno
fatto citazioni di gblan poi altri
autori e così via io cito un altro
grande pensatore del 900 che è John
bonobi grandissimo pensatore 900 che
dice in una canzone non so se è vero
perché non l'ho trovata ma mi fido delle
ricerche su Google è bella scrivi il tuo
futuro ma con una matita che per un
Capricorno come me che vorrebbe un Posca
tipo una cosa indelebile è
difficilissimo Grazie a tutte Grazie a
tutti